three nations commit
it was an unusual prelude to a biden
white house briefing a video extolling
the depth and length of the relationship
between the three countries
the only time the us has shared its
nuclear propulsion technology was with
the uk back in nineteen fifty eight
now australia will become part of this
exclusive club in an alliance labelled
alkus the us president joined remotely
by the other two leaders the first major
initiative of august will be to deliver
a nuclear-powered submarine fleet for
australia
over the next 18 months we will work
together to seek to determine the best
way forward to achieve this
only a handful of countries
possess
nuclear-powered submarines
and it is a
momentous decision
for any nation to acquire this
formidable capability
and perhaps equally momentous for any
other state to come
to its aid and president biden confirmed
a new emerging u.s strategy in the
indo-pacific region
we need to be able to address both the
current strategic environment in the
region and how it may evolve
because the future of each of our
nations and indeed the world depends on
a free and open indo-pacific enduring
and flourishing in the decades ahead the
announcement came only hours after north
and south korea conducted missile tests
in a ramping up of tension in the region
china was quick to make a call for
restraint
amidst mounting international criticism
the word china was not mentioned by any
of the leaders during the washington
announcement but there's no doubt that
what is regarded as chinese expansionism
is a motivating force for the formation
of this new alliance and clearly it
would appear china thinks so as well
the chinese embassy here in washington
has been quick to issue a statement
saying countries should shake off their
cold war mentality and ideological
prejudice
the uk and the u.s have long maintained
a significant naval and air presence in
the indo-pacific region in competition
with china
the injection of australian
nuclear-powered submarines could well
intensify this new cold war
under the water as well as above
mike hanna al-jazeera washington